he put this like a high electricity
under the wire fences of the entire
border put the machine guns with the
guards every 10 meters
and then on top of that he buries land
mines on the
entire border the entire country became
a concentration camp
so last year only two people escaped to
south korea
in the whole year the entirety of the
year two people made it out
you're on me park welcome to the show
thank you for having me chris
looking back now does it feel like a
dream when you think about
your time living in north korea totally
you know when i was watching this movie
called inception
right there's a very confusing part you
don't know what is dream anymore
and so when i dream interestingly enough
i am still in north korea
and this is the one thing that or that
north koreans share
after they even escape when they dream
they're still in north korea
so when we wake up we still think we're
in north korea sometimes we have to
remind each other it's not and so i
learned like how to pinch
myself that's why i heard like if you
pinch and if you're painful
that's like you know it's reality and so
i do pinch myself a lot many many days
what were you dreaming about when you
were in north korea
the themes are very similar right like
always how
do we find food you know begging the
neighbors
going around town and everything about
escape
how are we gonna escape there's flood
happening in the summer time
the guys is watching and always looking
for
ways to survive it's never about like
cheating and having a happy moment
or sometimes like i go back to north
korea and my
neighbors are recognizing me that i'm
the enemy
and they try to punish me so always like
that kind of dream like running away you
know
isn't it weird that while you were there
you were dreaming of being away
and while you're here you're now
dreaming of being back it's kind of like
you can never leave in a way
no i don't think it's possible yeah
i don't know what it is but all north
koreans
have that same theme i asked every north
korean that i meet
and they all say the same thing so
something about it i don't know why
i can i don't know what other distance
do like the people who escape cuba
venezuela if they do the same thing but
at least when you come to north koreans
we somehow not able to leave our you
know north korea in our dreams
what's the closest that you've been back
to north korea have you been to the
dmz i have not been to dmz but i've been
to very close north korea during the
balloon launches
i don't know if you heard about it there
are ngos that we
use balloons and sending leaflets
to north korea and it pops in in the
north korean
sky so inside the leaflets we have you
know
like you know talking about how kim's
are dictators
so during those blue launch we had to go
really near the border
where are you from north korea and south
korea from south korea
okay yeah and then you just put them up
let the wind carry them over and they
pop and
release pamphlets everywhere yeah
exactly
what do you think the likelihood of
people in north korea believing
what you've sent over because the
brainwashing is
pretty strong and it seems almost
unfalsifiable that
if you were to get these sort of
leaflets flown over
it's an easy excuse to say this is just
more propaganda from the west
this is america proving that they are
our enemies they're trying to brainwash
you away from us
they do that and i think in the past uh
north korea regime would
like circulate these rumors if you pick
up a leaflet or something it's gonna you
know it's gonna
your skin gonna fall off whereas you're
gonna become a deaf
or you're like coming and lose never
pick up something that was like you know
coming from other country however you
know people are so desperate
so they they eat whatever so we didn't
need like leaflets we put like one
dollar usd
and we also put some in a chocolate pies
i don't know what you know
that's like a light you know snacks so
they also
pick them up and eat them and and then
they realize okay we don't die but of
course if you're caught and doing it
somebody says that you're gonna be that
sentence or sent to concentration camp
and i met a lot of stereotype defectors
who were listening to and picking up
these leaflets
and learned about the truth and escaped
so i think i'm sure there are some
people do
not believe it but there's required some
people do change
their mind and eventually escape what's
a typical day
in a north korean person's life like
that is a good question because you know
north korea and lives are very
so in america even i was thinking about
thinking about the present right the
life of joe biden
and the some peasant life in america the
farmer's life
wouldn't be that different think about
it when they woke up
they're gonna have a shower they have a
running water
they have running electricity they have
tv they have running refrigerator
they have breakfast lunch dinner right
so even if you are like the trillionaire
life isn't that different compared to
somebody in the bottom
right even though homeless people here
can like eat and drink
but in north korea interestingly enough
they
made it uh they have a cat system
it is like very like ironic it's not
socialist paradise nobody should be like
everybody should be equal
but they initially they started country
as
making everybody equal but they made it
to big three characters of cast system
then within 3 characters they are
dividing into 50 different categories
so depending on what status your cast
you are in
your life is vastly different so
like my case i was born a middle class
where my father was a party member
but still middle class in north korea
you don't have running water
you don't even know what shower is you
don't even like have the 24 hours
electricity
you don't have cars public
transportation
you your days are always planned by the
party
i remember one thing i attracted when i
went to south korea someone gives
me this notebook and i was like planner
so i never seen a planner in my life so
what do you do with this like
oh it's the easiest of you what we're
gonna do with this day this
month you plan your year ahead and in
north korea
you can never plan your day that is not
even concept for us because we don't own
ourselves
in the the day before or the week before
we have somebody with the leader in the
family the town everybody
gotta be associate something in north
korea and they give us
our week's schedule so what would that
look like what would what would that
schedule look like
so it usually begins through the labor
so it doesn't pay you but we all
revolutionaries we gotta apply for the
revolution of the country right even
your kids
there's no such a concept of minor in
north korea or
elder so even if you're like five years
old
you gotta work so they basically they
say oh school kids this morning get up
at 5am
we go to some collective farm or we go
to railroad and break the rocks
well we go to them and we work for the
you know the construction workers
so from 5am we work until 8 a.m
then sometimes they ask us bring us our
breakfast or go home to eat breakfast
and then we go home to eat breakfast
then we have to go to school afterwards
then when you go to school we spend
three hours learning about the
revolution history and the greatness of
our dear leader
and how amazing they are after the
brainwashing is done
they say okay go to get lunch or bring
your lunch with you
but a lot of kids cannot afford to eat
so they don't eat lunch
then after lunch ends they take us to
the farm again
to collective farm or the factory all
the construction
works on but this thing is same thing
with the doors and the kids
we all have to work so entire afternoon
we spend on working
and then we work helping the farmers
with their harvest
when the thing ends they do let's go to
have dinner
and then sometimes they don't end the
labor until 10 pm or 11 p.m
then when that ends we go home eat
dinner and then you sleep out
that same schedule repeats next day we
wake up at 5am
and north korea has a radio that
that regime gives it for free right
everybody have to get ready about of
course it's like
all about brainwashing you and that also
radio tells you when to have dinner
when to have lunch when to get up like
everything is collectivism you cannot
choose like instead of your own alarm
like
i'm gonna get up like 10 say like nine
today
everybody have to work with the same
schedule
so that's the life of someone that was
middle class what about upper class
i don't even know but
because the thing is that in america the
i guess like mainly there's a middle
class
then some in the bottom and top right
but most of people still have like
somewhere in between the middle
lower middle middle and higher middle
but in north korea
most people in the poverty line like 90
of
them are poverty and within 10
that's like a middle class but then
within that 10 percent there's like one
top percent it's a
really small percentage of population
who are privileged
so they do of course have bands they
all these guys have their own pleasure
squad
they have a pleasure squad it's the
girls
they pick up around the country pick up
all the virgin girls who have
good family status and they train them
from their kids
and then when they become 16 or 17 years
old
they take them to the pyongyang capture
then they train them to be masseuse
dancer satisfaction group is like sexual
pleasure group
they divide in different like groups
then
there is a pleasure squad for the kim
kim jong-un
the second power the top elite guys all
have these groups
every year they get a new group to
please them
so their lifestyle is like unimaginable
they have private island they have yacht
they go to even study switzerland right
i mean kim jong-un went to school in
switzerland
so the top illiterate life is like
unimaginable life
that then even better than the u.s
presence like life
in some ways how's this enforced
how do you enforce such a rigid class
system
you well i mean in the beginning north
korea started as a communist
right kim your son came in and he was
the admirer of
learning and studying and marks then he
said okay
we don't like inequality so why don't we
communicate entire land from people and
especially the capitalists
so they were killing the capitalists and
getting all the lands from the
everybody and nationalize everything
then they say okay nobody wants anything
now there's no
private property that's how we eliminate
inequality right getting rid of
everything after that happened
and then kim's were thinking okay we
still need a ruling class
who knows better who decides the party's
direction
so they call like initially they call
themselves as the
servants of the people so if these
elites were working for
us and they said we are the servants for
you
and you guys are so grief you should be
so grateful that
we have these people wants to you know
sacrifice their life for the revolution
of our country
and then they and then they were
deciding collective forms everything is
collective
we decide who becomes farmers so the
party decides
so in north korea when you're born like
your life is determined before even your
birth
so when i went south korea they were
saying like what do you want to do you
do life
i was shocked you know when in north
korea when you're born
depending on what your great great
grandfather did
during the korean war or during the like
japanese colonialization
that my status is determined already by
the party
and i think that's the biggest
difference here is that people
can dream your life and design it what
you want to do but in north korea that's
not even like some
concept that people understand and then
if you mate
between different groups between
different castes
it's only a one-way system right if you
mate down
the person that is lower doesn't become
upper it's always the person that's
upper becomes lower so you have
an increasingly reducing number of
people that are at the top and
increasing the larger number of people
that are at the bottom
exactly so that's the thing like that's
how they prevent
mixing between classes the sacrifice
that you would have to pay
in order to mix between classes as the
higher position
would be to sacrifice your place yeah
it's really like it's so evil that way
they really prevent people to mix around
so they when there's no such thing in
north korea called like
marrying up you only marry down no
matter what
if you marry somebody lower you go down
with them you can never go up with them
how do people choose their partners then
let's say that it's not about
moving between different classes yeah
what does dating look like
in north korea so more the average
people
the peasants they are a little bit
patient
right so they are going to be forever
farmers but in north korea farmer means
if
you're emotionally not like you're going
to start to death like
farmers the regime little collective
harvesting
and then they take like 98 of the
harvest to the elites
so these entire farmers work in the farm
entire summer and fall in winter
they don't get much food they get like
few grains
few corns a day so they have to go
get the tree barks and to eat the bugs
and that's how they survive
so in north korea if you become a farmer
it's almost like if that sentence to you
it's uh it's there's really no hope of
surviving
so i think the regime is people i mean
dating is really like dating with
your circle but in the past though like
dating is romance is
really shameful thing so regime even the
gallery of mother say in 2017
because kim jong-un is so paranoid that
the
people's love for the mother gonna
distract their love for the leader
and the party so they deny every other
love
other than the love for the kings and
the party
so people used to be always through like
family
and etc or the party orders like these
girls who go become a pleasure squad
members
they get the order from the regime it's
called the assignment
so they assign who you should marry and
the elites to theirs or like
the regime assigns so somebody who met
kings right they become very
privileged then they set up a day for
them
so regime literally decides everything
for you
you don't have to do anything there
think is there a marriage ceremony
there is and then the first thing you
have to do is when you become a union
you have to go to a statue of kings and
pay the respect
and you know you gotta like you have
this like uh because it's kind of like
off that you're gonna become a good
union to support the socialist
revolution
and the way why you marry north korea is
not about expressing your love or
finding your soul mate
but because you want to serve the party
better become a better revolutionary
that's why you're marrying not for love
so immediately
after making vows to another person what
the regime's trying to do
is um redirect that emotion back to the
state straight away
yeah yeah that's yeah that's interesting
you said about the farmers and about the
fact that 98
of their produce gets taken away
i'm gonna guess that a lot of farmers
must try to sneak
bits of their crops to keep stuff behind
does that happen no then you're gonna be
kicked and
tortured and you're gonna send the
prison camp remember in china during the
mouth
of five years planning that
anybody who got food and got
out of the collective thing they get
severely severely punished
i mean you don't like this these people
when we say these officials
are not just like normal people they are
like the soul evil core
cruel like torture like guards are
almost military guards
in that environment you work it's a very
oppressive environment everybody is a
prisoner in north korea
so you cannot like dare to steer things
well you can literally in the consensual
camps right
the kids are working hard and they raise
peaks for the officials to eat and then
they feed these corns to pigs and when
they have fishes come out
and there's in between there's a corn
comes out and this
like people inmates eat that and they
the guys beat them
and torture them or even eating the corn
that's gone through a pig already
yeah so that's how they treat human
beings
and so if there's no way you can get
away if you get caught that's the
thing you you you get like become
handicapped or like sent to
camps again yeah so if
98 of the produce has been taken away
from the farmers
plus there's a famine amongst most of
the population
do you think that the there is
a bulk of food that's actually being
thrown away
at the top is it just is there more food
being produced than the people who are
allowed to eat the food can eat
so to hear that the north korea farm
really struggles
because they cannot even have a
fertilizer so
as a north korean kid we all have to
give things to the party initially they
promised that
we are going to give everything for free
to you guys so give us your liberty
we're going to take care of you but
eventually they'll
bring everything to us right we are the
ones that are keeping them alive
so because we don't have fertilizer
literally we have
assignment bring poop to school
and outdoors like in north korea there
are proof
diffs literally because you have
assigned to bring a one ton of
for each family or like 200 kilowatts
per student
so in the winter time you don't go to
school and then they kick you out of
this classroom and go
look for cook so because the farmers
need the fertilizer
and they cannot make the fertilizer so
we
need to bring feces that humans make so
and then we bring them to the farmers
then that's how you get all those
intestines the worms you get
like there's one soldier who got caught
and through the dmz
when he got to south korea they were
seeing these long long long worms in his
body and that is the biggest problem in
north korean people with the real crops
that were
the human physicism mix so that we have
so many diseases from that so the farm
bombing is not the harvest is not that
great
and there's so much uh bribery and
corruption
so when that happens and this elites
like take it away for themselves
and they themselves or don't give the
entire thing for the for the party
so it's like north korea is one of the
most corrupt countries in the world
and yeah how does the
prison system well i mean is there a
prison or is it just
forced labor camps and death so there
are three types of prison camps in north
korea
and there's two types of crime too so
one is political crime and second is
economic crime so even you rape somebody
or murder somebody i mean by the way
rave is not even crime in north korea we
don't even know what rape is
like if there's somebody raped like that
girl gets punished right they
it's i mean men have a pleasure squad
like we don't even know that
sexual harassment is a thing so like
that's not even crime so let's say
murder
murders even like get economic uh crime
because you've taken a worker away from
the party
but then that's they don't even punish
that much because human life doesn't
mean much in that country we don't even
know what human rights is
but most severe crime is a political
crime like let's say
your house cut off caught on fire you
have your children your mother all like
sleeping next to you but you have a
portrait of kim's every household have
the portraits of kim's
so what do you do in the house get
caught fire you don't want your children
on your arms
you have to protect the portraits
otherwise the
regeneration of that family get punished
or like if there's a newspaper
every newspaper front page you gotta
have the photos of kim's
but when you didn't see that and then
you see the back of the paper and you
reap
it by mistake that's when you go to
political prison camp
and that's a life sentence you never
kill them out and then you
take three generations of your family
with you so there are like
concentration camps that is a lifetime
sentence
then there is a labor camps
that is more like the murderers of
thieves
or like you know criminal citizen that
is like usually sentenced to come up
the last one is a labor camp a forced
labor camp that's a
more i mean re-education camp those are
more like one
between three years short amount of
sentence
and then of course there's a public
execution for somebody who cannot be
with him just they're gonna kill them
anyway
so usually those if somebody say oh i
don't believe in the party it's like
revolution ideology then that person
gets executed and the family members
usually go to concentration camp
and then they never come out and the
north korea needs this concentration
camp like inmates because they need to
do a lot of the
the chemical tests you know there's gas
chambers but north korea does a lot of
bio
this you know weapons so they need they
use
like inmates and you know do the orders
test on them
and then they they have to clean the
nuclear debris
so you know they get deformative and
they die
from a cancer so they keep creating
these
political prisoners to do all this job
that
they don't want the normal population to
be exposed to
well it's not just the public executions
that are executions then
there's a lot of other ways that you can
be forced to die
yeah in these different levels of of
prison
i lose your lifespan when you send to
political prison camp is three months
most of them do not last more than three
months
yeah so when you go to political prison
camp
it's better off to be signed right now
so
that's why when defectors escaping
myself
i we were ready to kill ourselves we
were not gonna go stand back and be
tortured then go to consensus
and die that's the most painful misery
where you can die
he was so certain that you would have
gone back and you would have been killed
that it's just easier to take your own
life instead of suffer
it's not just certainly the north korean
regime what they say so if
you go to china and then if you are
trying to escape the south korea
that's that sentence that's a public
execution or consensus in camp like
that's a law
so we all know that what the law says so
when north koreans
actually escape they all like you have
to kill themselves
can you explain about how the lineage
from
kim il-sung sort of through to now has
worked
because it's quite an interesting story
yeah so this is another irony right like
in communism you don't
have a king but north korea became a
kingdom
right the the king's kings became not
just a king they became a god
for north koreans they so interesting
about kim
song is that the first king his parents
were devout christians
so kim your son thought okay if i copy
bible
and tell him so when you become all god
you don't have to be logical
you don't have to explain why things
work the way right like
it's a higher power like you know you
don't try to understand god's logic
so it becomes much easier to brainwash
in population
so he literally copied the bible saying
i'm a god
i love you guys so much so i'm giving
you my son
kim jong-il who's gonna work for the you
know the revolution of the country
but his body dies but don't believe that
he
spirits with us forever therefore he
came with your thoughts and minds and
how many hair in your head exactly what
the bible says whether jesus came he
died
and he spiritual videos all the time and
that's how
i even believe that kim's were like
reading my thoughts
i was even afraid to think people in
north korea
the thought crime my thinking is not
like free
so that's how kimberson came as a
communist
and then he making this country
confiscate all the land
nationalize everything and he was i
think
more dreamer he really wanted thought i
think communism would work
i don't know what he thought but however
when it came to his son
they knew that this thing is for
themselves obviously
and brutally purge every time the new
king comes
and now kim jong-un time the top of
fisher's
lifespan is only three years too so kim
jong-un
is killing everybody every three years
so
they don't get corrupt and then
consolidate power
so it cannot start the cool so when you
become a type elite
if you're staying a long time you are
going to cause consolidate power and get
the build allies
but kim don't execute them and punishing
them
every three years by doing that he get
eliminates any competition
where do you think the paranoia comes
from is this something that
they've been taught by their parents
have they got a
very strong genetic trait for just being
unbelievably anxious what's going on
i think they they even know what they're
doing is not acceptable
right like i mean he was killing uh
this type of vision in a meeting because
he was falling asleep
in a minute and then that guy right next
hour get executed the fire squad
right so she knows that people are being
loyal to him and people are
living in that country not just because
they want to live there it's just out of
fear they're doing it
so i'm sure everybody he knows that so
clearly that
he's controlling the people through fear
only
nobody loves him nobody actually care
take care of him and nobody wants to be
royalty on their own
so i think in a way that paranoia is a
legitimate
but she doesn't have to be that way
right if he tries to make things really
better
and why would anybody not want to be
there
it's interesting it's like a vicious
cycle when you mistreat people
because as you mistreat them they have
less faith in you which means that you
need to use more force in order to get
them to comply
which means that they believe in you
less which means you need to mistreat
them more which means you believe in you
less
and you can see how this happens i am
it's crazy thinking about this slow
descent as well as you say
it looks 50 years ago like there might
have been a genuine dream that this
could have worked with some sort of a
balance
what do you think what do you think was
the worst
period for to be alive in north korea
over the last whatever sort of 60 years
or so 70 years
worst period i think is definitely the
90s after soviet collapse right so in
the north korea began in the 50s
after the world war ii the japan left
and the korea became independent
and korean war begins and then of course
america come defend south korea
so everything departed in 1953
from there on north korean economy was
heavily subsidized by soviet union and
china
because that was a cold war they wanted
the communism to win
so they were like why even the soviet
union going bankrupt themselves
they're heavily subsidized north korean
economy
but when they collapsed in 89 uh north
korea
that's when they really knew that coming
doesn't work
and you just spend everybody's money and
that's it everybody become dirty poor
right
so in the 90s that's when the regime
decided that okay
the only success measure that we are
going to have
is keeping the 10 of the population
alive
that's for them is a success so as long
as they maintain 10 percent alive
they think they do not have to do a
thing about it
so until the 90 percent all die they're
gonna do a thing about it
so this is why also they want the
population to be weak
why do they starve us even though the
international community
begging north korea to feed its own
people
they want to give money the u.n wants
begging to give food
right but north korea regime says no to
all the aids and
all the medical aids and the reason why
they do that is that because
it's so easy to control people when
they're hungry
like in north koreans what we do is that
when we get up we eat the breakfast
right
and what we are thinking is how are we
gonna find lunch once you lunch like oh
how
am i gonna make like fine dinner if you
make the one day you think okay i made
one day on earth how am i gonna make
tomorrow
you tomorrow is never guaranteed for you
you don't know like how you're gonna be
tomorrow
so in that mind people are very occupied
just survivor
and then then they are not gonna even
think about what is dictatorship what is
freedom
what is the outside world look like they
don't care about that
and kim jong-un have every every reason
to stop the population and
he's using the most inhumane culture
to be of god right now it's very
difficult to think about putting a
revolution together
when all that you need to worry about is
your next meal for you and your family
yeah it's such a
it's such an effective control mechanism
obviously it's
awfully brutal but it works it gets the
job done
of not permitting any
mental freedom for people to think of
those higher abstractions i mean you
know for you to think
to be surprised by a day planner
yeah what's a day planner why would i
need to plan my day that's planned by
the state
yeah why didn't kim jong-il's
eldest son become leader
so kim jong-il didn't the kim jong-un
who got assassinated by
so yeah that's an interesting story uh
kim jong-un had
four wives official wives and then like
how many ministries we we don't even
know there's gonna be armies of them
so among those four kim jong-nam is
coming from the first
wife that which is allergic to my wife
and he was really loved by kim jong-il
however around like early 2000
kim jong-nam was visiting japan to go to
disneyland with a fake passport
on the way back he got called and
journalists took photos of him
and then it became an international like
embarrassment because north korea is all
about hating the west
by hating america hating japan hearing
the western civilization
and here is the heir to north korean
throne going to disneyland
so it was such an embarrassment and
that's when kim jong
kim jong-il were like almost banished to
him
and that's how he but the thing is kim
jong-nam was a
way more free spirit he wasn't
interested in like power he wasn't
interested in control
he was more interested in like opening
up the economy let's
learn from the west let's learn like
what we can do better
and he was more like a flavor of a
chinese direction that chinese communist
party to which is the opening of the
economy
we don't have to change the party
communist party
but can we alice open the economy so
people get
fit fit fed but of course nursing regime
like
then no we don't want that so his
ideology
did not mean that what his father
dreamed of
and then his third wife which was also
plagiar squad that she was i think a
dancer
and she had a son kim jong-un which was
a second son
not even the first one he was very
ambitious
she was very brutal and cruel like his
own father
she kim jong-il saw kim jong-un and then
like oh my god i see myself in you
so you are gonna be the next cheerleader
and he became one
so the kim jong-nam i'm trying to keep
up with all the names here
he um he was misaligned to be the sort
of leader that everybody needed in any
case
do you think he was killed only a couple
of years ago he was assassinated
um but it seems like the trip to japan
was a convenient excuse
for somebody that probably didn't meet
the criteria to be a leader in any case
yeah no he wasn't gonna be that ruto and
kill the
uncle like literally kim jong-un is way
more brutal any previous skins
he used this like aircraft that shoots
down the airplane
he used that to execute people so it
makes the people become a dust literally
like
you become into pieces of this blood and
just like that's a thing
that's how it executes people and to
show the actual terror
and but as you said right you got to use
more fear as the time goes by
and more fear and fear fear and there's
no ever ending to it
and kim jong-un like literally when he
executing his own uncle
said she has no place to be buried in
this land
so make him into dust that's why he they
use the aircraft that's
gone almost to shoot him down so he
became into pieces and nobody could
collect his bodies
what was the what was the outcome
because he got was a nerve agent
in singapore or japan
no malaysia that was abrupt that was a
brother
but the uncle when kim jong-un was
killing his uncle
by the kim jong-nam's case like the
nerve agent that they wrapped in his
nose and face and then he just died
within a few minutes
and his body was sent to pyongyang
afterwards and we don't know what they
did with his body but
he was killed in the and it was so sad
because
he was providing information to the u.s
intelligence
for the last 10 years and then u.s
didn't do a
thing about protecting him like he was
on that tree meeting a cia agent in the
northern island of malaysia for two days
after he was giving all the information
and when he was about to go home back to
his family
they killed him and this is so sad like
nobody protects anybody at this point
did you hear the story of why the two
women that rubbed the rag in his face
did it
or why they said so they claimed that
they
were that they'd been told that they
were doing a prank on a tv show
is that right yeah they they thought oh
this is gonna be some prank tv show
this makes no sense i mean these girls
were like
not touching themselves the thing they
were going washing their hands like very
carefully that
i mean if that was a prank why would
they do that so but the thing is point
is that i think even those girls were
victims
they were i don't i don't really don't
think that's
important they knew or not the most
important thing is
how there is no revenge or no
accountability
you know but even jamal khashoggi the
saudi journalist
we all know that when he got chopped off
into pieces in the saudi council in
turkey
there's no consequences for killing a
distance
that is the word that we are living in
like of course people talk about
injustice or any other time but
this is a clear injustice these are
clear murderers
it's a great control mechanism right if
as a dissident
you know that not only are you probably
going to be killed
but the people that are going to kill
you aren't going to be brought to
account
and the more that this happens the more
that dissidents killers
aren't put on trial or aren't called to
account for the things that they've done
the more fear it instills in people that
want to speak out against regimes that
need it
and the more it empowers the regimes
that want to control the population
absolutely i mean when the men putin
like poisoned his distance
i mean mbs saudis do that north koreans
does that like even
there's really no accountability at this
point and this is
i think one of the justice area that we
are struggling
and i think that's this is i don't know
how to even solve this but the thing is
what a joke the immune saudis in chinese
and russians deciding who are the human
rights violators
at the u.n so this is a almost a joke to
me that
michael is a joke michael malus will
have a solution for this he's always got
a solution for
for mad anarchy lordship different
countries
all right so how how does north korea
make its money
if it doesn't tax its citizens
well i mean they they own us so
they so many ways so number one is they
are the biggest
uh exporter of crystal meth and rpm
you're kidding me
they're the biggest exporter of crystal
meth
yeah and opium so they
in north korea they cultivate opium
in the schoolyards literally every i
remember playing with
cutie pretty flower and my mom studied
the chemistry
in the university and her colleagues
were picked up to go to his
labs to making all these drugs to sell
right
so north korea 60 of the even teenagers
got addicted to
these drugs because when you are still
in nursery you don't have medicine
free health care but like i had my
appendix removed
there is like no anesthesia they caught
bones with diagnosed tissue so when
people get sick
they take the drug to relieve the pain
and that's how they become
like when little toddler gets cold and
they don't know what to do ammonium
ammonia or something
then parents give them like opium to
relieve the pain
and we don't even know what this thing
is because regime cultivates it right we
don't have a knowledge of it
so they start the christian map they
export it everywhere to the world
and then they sell a lot of message to
the middle east
so all those words are happening in the
middle east that all those weapons are
sold
by the north koreans selling missiles
weapons
and they were also selling that's the
nuclear
uh the strategy the technology to
iranians pakistani and they're selling
those like
how to build nuclears for the dictators
right
they have the time to work for that to
go for and not only that they share
their own people
they sell their workers to africa so
there's a lot of
dictators in africa so these north
korean workers go to africa and
and build the statues for the dictators
because north koreans are good at
building statues right that's like what
all we got so all the statues you see
of dictators in africa are booked by
north koreans
and then that's in the world they works
in qatar poland
in siberia in china and they work as a
korean wood
or there's like really going to minor so
would it be if you were chosen to go to
one of these other countries
presumably you're going to live under
slightly
more luxurious circumstances than you're
going to
no you're going to be even worse in
poland or in africa absolutely
they build a camp for you when you go
abroad
they build a camp like prison camp
and all the banners about the propaganda
banners and
statues and the portraits of kim's and
then they are not free to leave that
that that building or the camp and
there's a revised documentary they
needed
about these people working in siberia a
north korean workers
they got zero zero freedom and they work
15 hours a day without
any even like safety equipment
and the entire money they make go into
the regime
so their food even quality is so so they
are so
like hungry they are like eating the
trash that other people like throw away
but they can't even go out
so there's somebody who's in charge go
out and picking up trash food and bring
that to them
and even though of course north koreans
are grateful and they go like syria even
before i mean
they they go all around the countries
and north korea and also women
now it's like a child they are trying to
attract the chinese tourists to north
korea
and the government wants waters so they
can attract the chinese tourists
to come and have sex with these youngers
and of course the entire money goes to
regime
and then have these restaurants right
the north korean restaurants in china in
a lot of european countries
these girls go and they have to perform
and sing and make the food
but they they cannot leave the building
i was in london last year
and michael texted me and said you
should really go to this restaurant
but you can't you don't say
anything don't tell them that i've
suggested that you should go don't
mention my name don't do this that in
the other
uh do you think that might be one of
them in london is there one in london
i'm not sure exactly in london some of
them in other european countries like
vienna i heard
and tons of them china russia
in cambodia laos i mean thailand
uh really all around the world maybe
madness is just trying to get me
kidnapped maybe
maybe he's trying to send me somewhere
where i'm gonna get i'm gonna get to but
they do kidnap people
it's not a joke they're looking at
people they have all cameras
and then if they come into somebody they
recognize as valuable
they kidnap them yeah it's they
because i mean north korea like kidnaps
those japanese citizens remember in the
past
they kidnapped everyone in the world to
come to north korea
and then they use them as a training
spies and teaching them the language
yeah so north korea kidnaps so many
japanese people
and so many people all around the world
and not only that one day kim jong-il
was like okay i like
sushi and i like to really have a good
sushi so what do they do
what do you think they did kidnapped a
bunch of japanese sushi
chefs restaurants yeah exactly they went
to japan
and connected one of the best sushi chef
and then kings and when they said i
really want to make good movies in north
korea
so why would they i remember this i
watched this on the new netflix series
where
he kidnapped the man and his wife right
yeah the
the biggest movie directors in south
korea
and they kidnapped them through hong
kong so that's okay they they kidnapped
people
it's not a joke they were is trying
to stitch me up and get me kidnapped
through a north korean restaurant in
london i'm going to be pissed
all right so do you know how many
defectors have left
north korea have you got any idea so
here's the thing
uh nobody knows that's a clear answer
but we can estimate
there are now 33 000 north korean
defectors in south korea
and then america is only over 200
defectors and you can actually get a lot
i'm sure it's like several
lesson thousands but still bigger than
american community
and there are about up to 300 000 north
korean defectors in china
hiding and became enslaved by chinese
people so but then we don't even know
how many died along the journey like
my father died who never made it and we
knew so many people died in
the journey so we don't know how many
left and died and made it
but right now approximately 300 000
nursing defectors in china
for modern day slaves and
very few in the us and some in the uk
and south korea is a major but the thing
is after kim jong became
in power he literally of course
country cannot even afford electricity
he put this like a high electricity
under
the wire fences of the entire border and
that's not even there
put the machine guns through the guards
every 10 meters and then on top of that
he buries land mines
on the entire border so entire country
became a concentration camp
so last year only two people escaped to
south korea
in the whole year the entirety of the
year two people made it out
but the thing is they were not even
coming from north korea
they were coming from the ones who
already escaped china and then
escaped there's no new escape from
coming from north korea anymore so the
defection kind of stopped at this point
is the worst place for someone that's
north korean to be after north korea
china yeah of course yeah
it's i don't know even how to say worse
what's worse
right like in north korea you you can
die from starvation but at least there's
some dignity you don't get raped you
don't get
like swords you don't get as long as you
don't go to concentrating camp but when
north koreans go there
we like if we become my kids they say
even if i kill you
we cannot go to chinese police right
because the chinese region going to
catch a senate back
so then basically they can rape you they
can rip you and they can take your
organs out
why china is the biggest organ provider
because i mean they get they got
xinjiang riggers they got
falun gong people they got tibetan they
koreans
so north koreans when they go to china
uh if you're unlucky you go
get your organ style and die uh
if you better chances of you surviving
the country is becoming a golden bronzer
and get raped every single second or
being married to chinese farmers and
who's gonna beat you and torture you
or like there are towns like the entire
town canal for the women
so they buy one girl and the entire man
in the town
raped them around and they
you this is the 21st century and this is
happening right now
and of course the mainstream media do
not talk about this because this chinese
communist party
nobody wants to you know attack them
they want to
have a business in china so even
hollywood
all talk about this justice whatever
thing is they don't want to cover this
why aren't they covering north korea
because china
china sponsors kim jong-un and hollywood
gets
funding from china but they need money
and they need to sell their movie in
china
american corporation like like even like
nba
lebron james look at him when he says
right john cena recently
you see the john cena thing where he did
that struggle session apology
ah shame on humanity i'm like this is
unbelievable this is
unbelievable this is the worst regime
that
exists in this today's world they won
north korea they won
i mean they genocided xinjiang riggers
their birth rates their 47 percent
last year because they uh
infertile everybody they give them like
this is the vitamin why you don't you
take
giving them shots make them they cannot
reproduce
this is genocide and this in chinese can
still be around
and there are so many people say oh how
about america america is worse than
china right
it's just it it's such an interesting
time to be
living in in this country right now
there's no more virtue there's no more
justice it seems like
it does really feel like there's this
huge blind spot
i i understand that commercial interests
mean
that certain organizations will
pay huge prices in order to criticize
china
but it's a it surprises me in a world
that's so decentralized where you have
individual creators that can put things
out on youtube or
even blockchain hosted video hosting
websites now you have people with huge
huge platforms that are talking about
everything anything and everything there
is a topic
and a reddit thread and a discord server
and a
you know there's a twitter account for
it it seems
so bizarre to me that there's this huge
human rights violation going on
that nobody's paying any attention to
and yet
animal rights global warming are these
huge movements have you got any idea
why culturally
it's not being picked up more by people
because whatever these twists the
people's minds they got
right whatever thing i mean the thing is
people america especially obsessed with
slavery
i mean it happened sorry 18th century it
happened a long time ago
and there are literally people right now
being enslaved in this 21st century
so the thing is if the slavery that
matters that happened like
a few centuries ago why this library is
happening right now it's not matter
to you and that's the the biggest
hypocrisy is that
if the song slavery matters why this
kind of slave that doesn't bother you at
all
right this is why it's all about how
this
became almost like identity politics
it's all about their narrative
all about winning their own power so
i think this we are seeing that i mean
we know that hitler
became voted to come into power he
didn't like
start a coup people voted for him to
become the power
and venezuela too right even cuba as
well it wasn't
so even north korea keemer's song too
like people voted for him
we wanted him and there is no
no guarantee it's not gonna happen in
the west it is possible i mean it
happened
not to germany so that i think
when people lose that what is right
they lose a sense of i think right now
it's like
everything i mean the biggest problems
these kids that have i saw at columbia
the their pronouns if somebody don't
know do not call their right pronoun
what is this
whatever this weird word x y z whatever
this thing is
this is the biggest oppression they ever
feel in their lifetime
and we are raising a generation or
brainwashing a generation think
that is the biggest problem in the world
and they're
keeping them in the bubble like they do
not understand
how rare it is for the individuals to be
free
and even know what individualism is like
in north korea
there is no word for i we don't even
know the word i
so when i went to south korea they were
asking introduce yourself
and this is all north koreans do like we
from north korea
we from heisen we love like this food
and they're like what do you mean we
like you you i and in north korea that's
how
they like even get rid of this concept
like freedom
human rights and i and the fact that we
know what i
is that's a privilege and of course
these people for them is the biggest
oppression is that you know
the pronouns so
yeah i don't know i'm are you hopeful
not really to be honest yeah i mean it
seems like
china is such an obvious target
for everybody to be concerned about the
militarization of the south china sea i
watched some documentary about this the
other day
that's terrifying they are
taking over territory in northern
pakistan
they've got this belt and road
initiative they are exporting more and
more technology around the world they've
got disinformation campaigns
and then you see how easy it is to
socially or culturally hijack
countries like the uk or the us with
particular movements
and even now
the skepticism around is this actually
people from
the uk or the us talking about this
problem online
or is this just state actors from russia
or from
china that are talking about this when
you combine all of this and then
what i really would love to educate
myself more on is
the long-term plans of china i know
obviously there's no booklets somewhere
where they've just said oh this is what
we fancy doing
but obviously the rumors and the obvious
impact implication is that they would
want to expand the ccp across the entire
world
and like that's an existential threat
that's a threat to the entire globe
yeah and because
companies want to make money and because
governments don't want to lose out on
import and export duty
or don't want to make waves nobody's
talking about
it like if you leave a problem longer
and longer
it just gets harder and harder to fix
and
i mean what more obvious of a potential
issue could you have than a global
pandemic released from
perhaps a wuhan lab like
it's just an endless there's an endless
laundry list an endless laundry list of
things that have happened
that should have caused some
repercussions for china
there's zero reproduction right i mean
they are
blaming people saying it's coming from
china and they they call us
racist that's what they're
spending their energy on right it's like
um
i mean it's coming from china we know
that
and china even if it's not coming from
the lab let's say that let me move that
it was happening in china they had to
report to the world organization
be transparent about it right we could
have ended there if we knew all what it
was
they had all the genetic code of coffee
and they could
they that was their duty to report
health organization
warning everybody what was happening
they didn't do that they would keep
saying no it's nothing it's nothing
no transmission no nothing so even
that was enough for them to be hold
accountable
for what they have done to entire
humanity they cared
more than 2 million people around the
globe imagine americans do that
can you imagine like if the uk did that
the world is going to attack us all if
chinese does it
of course like all everybody's defending
them right now
even though people in america is
defending them and i'm not sure if
anyone's defending them
i think that people are willfully being
ignorant to them
i think that people aren't pointing the
finger in the way that they should
um but yeah i wonder whether
the deconstruction of patriotism and of
pride in
countries like the uk and the usa
it wouldn't so i mean if it's not russia
or china's plan
they must be sitting back and thinking
they're just doing our work for us
because the one thing that would work
against an aggressive nation state like
russia or china
would be a proud country that said
we want to protect our national
sovereignty
we're concerned about what's happening
over there and you create an
in-group and out-group dynamic right you
have the out-group that's china we need
to protect ourselves perhaps we're
stewards of the earth
you know usa used to be the people team
usa i know it's a
a satirical movie but that the whole
movie was all about
them being guardians of the globe and um
because national pride's been
disintegrated a lot
especially over the last two years
no one really wants to stand up for that
anymore it's very uncool
you've got this fragmented idea about
what it means to be an american or a
patriot
people are embarrassed about their
country's history do you think this
this is the perfect breeding ground
for an aggressive party to come and take
over
because no one's going to fight back but
that's the thing i think
it's not just that this happened this
way at this point i think
some kind of behind the scene thing have
infiltrated
this way i don't think american people
chose to be this way and be
so ungrateful and so ignorant of the
past and the history right like
i mean slavery began the dawn of
humanity
it's still happening and still holding
the slavery pissing against the
entire american nation and saying this
country
only solution to this country is tear
down everything
and we build something right that's the
thing these people in the u.s now
voluntarily want to bring down the
country
bring down the system and bring i mean
like get rid of this constitution right
so but i don't know that's just began
on their own or somebody who were
influenced it
feels like they've been hijacked somehow
doesn't it yeah
it just feels like it's not a conspiracy
theory at this point
how the country making that much
progress
right like from there to here we have
made so much progress as a humanity
coming here but suddenly
going against exact system allowing this
progress to happen
and do not want to kind of going back
and what what is this everything is
reversing the regression is happening
right now voluntarily
and i don't know what happened how it is
possible
well isn't it crazy that you have north
korea a country with very low living
standards
where the population is forced to love
the country
and america a country with very high
living standards
where the population is now hating the
country yes
it's so backward this is the only
country i saw that people
hate the country but i want to be here
how many people
i want how many people trying to come to
this country if this is
really that bigotry and systemically
racist country
the worst country you think is why
everybody trying to come and why would
you not even live
go away just go to north korea if you
want that much just go to china
right nobody trying to immigrate to
north korea and china
and that's the thing that proves this is
a good great country and
now i think that becomes very
controversial right
what have been some of the repercussions
of you defecting have you ever been
threatened or has there been
intelligence surveillance ever done on
you or anything like that
well i mean we're gonna even begin uh
when i
spoke out south korea of course
intelligence informed me
that i um i'm on the killing list of kim
jong-un
and kim jong-un's killing this is not a
joke right if you want to kill
somebody's like kill somebody so
it was it was good over south korean
intelligence informed me that so i
appreciate it
but i mean we know that no country gonna
protect me if he don't only kill me he's
gonna go
ahead and do it and there's of course no
repercussion for doing that
uh not only that though i expected that
to happen but
of course because i spoke out everybody
that i left
behind the three generations of my
family
and even including my neighbors had
denounced me
on youtube that north koreans should
have the propaganda channel you know to
me that i'm the puppet of the west
propaganda of the west
and this is all the bizarre thing about
youtube is talking about the fake thing
and the censoring people they send
my videos but they do not answer the
video made by the north korean
dictatorship
it is hilarious you two can see that
video and then all my families are gone
afterwards
and i don't know if they've been
executed or sent to produce in camps
and of course after that north korea had
a smear campaign
against me creating north korea another
way of their making money is through
hacking did you hear that how many
became
bitcoin they store and how many uh
hackers they raised so they attacked
even
the uk health insurance companies they
have done it
of course so they they do hackers they
create so many smear campaign against me
so that's what they are good at the
character assassination
so what did that i was going to say what
what were the
accusations about your character so it
was that i'm a cia spy so i get paid
from the cia and saying
lies and then i lied north korea has no
starvation is the best country on earth
and everything is good but she's trying
to become a sensational
saying that there's a poverty there's
oppression and the lying about means
that
uh the worst thing that came up was that
i was very individualistic
and ambitious as a young girl in north
korea being ambitious and
individualistic is like the worst thing
can be right so on the video they say
she was the poisonous mushroom that grew
up in a pile of trash
so she was younger so ambitious and so
individualistic
and in the west like that thing is
embraced here
and of course another thing they they
make
problem is that i said i climbed the
mountain
before my escape to cross the river but
they went to google maps
and google that they measured the
altitude of the mountain but then
the altitude wasn't mountain it was high
here
but as a young girl how do i know what
altitude do you call that here
or mountain i still don't know oh so
they
used a discrepancy in how high the hill
was
versus a mountain to discredit whether
or not
you would lived in the place that you
live so what was the implication of that
you were never in north korea
no no no thank god north korea comes
before then there's you know a lot of
sympathizers of the communist party so
they were saying
they went to google map and checked and
then
what she climbed was not here i mean he
was in the mountain he wasn't here
and then norris then eventually they say
why does she even speak english
she's not like north korea and she's a
fake person like pretending to be north
korean
but thank god north korea released my
birth certificate
and they really released my father's
birth certificate they released my
father's sentences to
labor camp and my mom's like
entire record so i am confirmed north
korean thank god
but the sympathizers that idi is asking
me so what's your password
show me your password how do i know that
you're north korean so i'm like
if i have a passport why would i even
escape i would have flew here right why
would i even cross a coffee desert
so this is how dumb the world is
i just cannot even fathom but thankfully
north korea confirmed that
my name is yummy park i was born in this
year that day
and you're on the kill list exactly so
they did
way more good to me than bad because
in america i mean i don't know in the
west people really sympathize north
korea and hate america
and north korea is the enemy of america
therefore they love north korea
so i became the target from the marxists
vietnamese
maoists communists and of course like
anti-western people everybody
and and now i'm the enemy of the work
so i have a lot of enemies there's a big
list you're on everyone's kill list well
look
exactly if people want to check out more
of your stuff where should they go
yeah they can come to my youtube channel
it's called the voice of north korea
and they can find me on twitter and you
know
instagram not on tick tock though
everything else yeah you're me park
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for coming on
thank you chris thank you very much for
tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace